[Musica]
allora quando siano questi regali
allora qual è il mio regalo
questo perché lo voleva mandare indicano
un detto dice regali non dovrebbe e il
tuo l'ho lasciato a casa
sguardi giuro scusami la prossima di
proporta spieghiamo tra settimana due
bellissimo regalo e mi stupirò e quindi
regalo ma i giudici per la gianni questo
star cinese quindi più che rende scelta
ragazzi spero che vi piace e porto
quando è diventato serio lo sapevo mi
sarebbe piaciuto
la sciarpa di barberino 16 ragazzi e
dagli allora ti chiamo prima non vedo
l'ora
una borsa dell'acqua calda penosa è
sempre dolosa più da pensate bella bella
grazie piero che grazie papà computer
nuovo traffico di calzini conte morelle
i computer sono il regalo bellissimo
grazie papà veramente troppo top ten i
mari questo è perché grazie guarda
bellissima però che forse mi sta un po
giusta forse non so così per sicurezza
mirallas continuo magari da cambio
magari allarmista è però celebrino
contando poi trovato zio toni grazie di
atari
62 euro e 30 ha superati 2 avrebbe
dell'anno scorso ti giuro ieri ho
pensato proprio bisogno di due presine
per la cucina ricevere tra il pesciolino
sognato ieri notte guarda credimi
bellissimo invece riprende la mia cucina
sperpero grazie dei pantaloncini per
andare a correre scuse per non andare in
palestra
stai dicendo la sua casa con questo
regalo che vuoi dire che ho bisogno
della ri palestra e non ci si perché mi
ha fatto questo regalo ma qualità di
regata ecco quanto regalano ai grazie
che cos'è questa morta ciò che stai
scherzando
e pura blast e via io neanche se mi
impegnassi che la collegano così di
merda riconoscere fatto così a caso
questo regalo di non mettere mano come
nel genere ma ecco questo regalo marito
grazie è carino grazie a te ne vai
e tu come reagisci quando aprì regali di
natale
lascia un commento qua sotto